wayne rooney's moving his family across
the Atlantic for a new life in America
his wife Colleen has just arrived and
they need to house hunt somewhere with
space for their four sons it'd be
difficult or and once we get ours in my
family and me boys are in school and
okay then that will obviously make it a
lot more easier than me getting more
into a routine and routine of living
I've had a chat with David Beckham about
how to do that no I think left obviously
Isis or the stuff off the pitch which
was commercial stuffing and different
stuff like that which the former England
captain is one of the highest-paid
players in Major League Soccer for just
a few weeks into his three and a half
year contract with Washington's DC
United
he's got a challenge on his hands the
teams at the bottom of the table he's
leading a very young squad and
expectations are high in America do you
want goals they want attacking play all
the time and which maybe adds to a bit
of the excitement of the game but
sometimes two minutes were on the pitch
did you save a little bit and see the
game out rather than just keep going and
going
that happened to me with some of the
older plays the likes of Ryan Giggs here
in poor schools he knew the right time
to you know see the game out or the
right time the ball in person thanks for
saving it ya know it's nice when he says
he's here to compete and win off the
pitch there's an added bonus to us life
he he can blend in with the tourists
without being mocked and it's a welcome
break I was it in England since I was 16
and I'm sure you speak to anyone who can
close with family and friends it's not
what I'm not particularly like I like in
here it's a bit more of relaxed people
to spend our naked and not stopping all
the time and not on three pitches north
scratch all the time and
and if that literally just give them the
attention which they need
can you see yourself staying and
settling in America I don't know I think
it depends on your family and how they
settle in and I've talked a lot of their
time time off over the years and you
know where you can't do things together
because of football so when I finish
playing and if you wanna stay here then
I'll stay don't go on my wrong way me
thank you very much this guy News
absolutely a pleasure thank you